i look at what aoc is doing as extremely
destructive
and the the drama politics the snapback
clapback stuff is really really bad for
for our political environment
it's got to be called out it's got to be
talked about get used to it bro
oh i know i know i mean future it was
yes absolutely it is it is reality tv
politics it's idiocracy
and trump is to blame for a lot of it as
well but trump didn't create it
aoc didn't create it it's it's a natural
byproduct of humans
i actively tried to create it in 2007.
youtube video blogs talking about
becoming the president using internet
video to interact where you don't need
secret service you can have
leaders from around the world on skype
together and
but we're not talking about talking
about barack obama getting him up that's
the first internet president
but that's not what we're talking about
what we're talking about
is instead of saying let's do a live
show
where the president can talk to the
constituents about new healthcare policy
it's more like i'm running for the
democratic party because jack murphy's
a [ __ ] burn yo high five me luke yeah
jack what do you got to say to that i
just roasted you on tv vote for me
there's gonna be a lot of that and i
think that trump and aoc are similar in
that both of them
this is my take are following their
instincts and it's not
uh as proactive and deliberate as my as
people might ascribe to them
uh i don't give either one of them that
much credit i just think that they're
being themselves
going with the flow feeling the energy
right i mean social media people you
know what the energy's like
you put something out you get the energy
back you're like all right dude just
like you're saying you do
you do more of that like i know exactly
what kind of topics get
high engagement for me on twitter i know
which ones that don't
i still do ones that don't because it's
true to me
but if you're just following the energy
it's it's a
it they're it's bro it's being drawn out
of them
as well for you're right for aoc
and and for trump you know trump would
tweet up a storm and he'd switch
like we long talked about how there
would be some drama or a lawsuit for
instance
there's a really funny moment where
trump changed the asylum rules
and it was the one time no one cared
about trump's moves towards like
immigration why
because he tweeted the squad should go
back to where they came from
and then come back or whatever trump
knew he could tweet
and shift the focus away from the things
he was working on and he did
you're right i think aoc knows how to
generate press attention
gain more followers you got 12.2 million
and
i think for uh channels like this look
you're gonna you're you'll get a lot of
grifters people who
similarly know what they can talk about
in order to generate a ton of press
dude we we'd all be better off playing
minecraft
doing scare vlogs you know like jump
scares and pranks
it does it does so much better and so
it's it's weird to me that there are
people who are grifters who choose
politics as their as their path
really because it's like bro you could
just make minecraft videos
and do better if you applied yourself in
the same way the hard work you would be
the biggest
video game fortnite you know call of
duty whatever channel
you streamed it politics is not where
you want to go for this stuff
politicians however it's exactly the
game they have to play
and then they need other people to prop
them up so there is an element when it
comes to
political commentary from left or right
of propping up the politicians they like
and trying to win some political battle
but i truly believe that right now the
space we are in
has nothing to do with politics that's
why they say you know tim poole is far
right or whatever even though i'm like i
like universal health care with with
with private supplemental insurance
that's a right-wing position apparently
but it's because i'm critical of their
tribe
so it's really just tribal politics
that's right aoc
can lie and be caught and they will
defend her
and say you're far right truth be told
donald trump even said he could shoot
someone on fifth avenue and not lose a
voter
because it was it was very tribal now
truth be told i think
in in the precursor to this new era
trump was pushing policies people liked
and because of that he generated a large
tribal base which expanded
into a tribal base specifically but a
lot of people
supported trump on his policy notably i
did i voted for him because of school
choice because of
his later attempts to withdraw from
afghanistan and the abraham accords et
cetera
but now what i think we're going to be
moving into as trump leaves with aoc now
getting 12.2 million followers
is going to be absolute drama
youtube style she'll make a video being
like you know ted cruz
he was saying this ted cruz i challenge
you to a rap battle and then ted cruz is
going to come out and being like yo aoc
what up let's rap and it's going to get
ridiculous
not really ted cruz could be like ted
cruz is already playing basketball with
jimmy kimmel boom there you go so
it's already happening it's already here
and the the the bastardization
of just the media space just to get the
clicks just to get the attention just to
get the paris hilton pr model
running which is essentially what we're
on and again we have to look i i've been
saying this i sound like a broken clock
it's a lot to do with the algorithms
sound like a broken
i had to laugh at that potato potato you
know what i'm trying to say here yes
uh i have to laugh at myself here
again where we're going to is just
idiocracy times 10 but i think a lot of
this is incentivized by the big tech
algorithms the big tech oligarchs who
are
controlling what we see controlling
what's popular controlling what we don't
see and
i think that perspective is is
essentially really really critically
important moving forward because that
power
is everything like the cortez obviously
had this moment where she was like i'm
feel i know that the robin hood thing
scandal is going on i know that i could
talk about the sec in the banking
industry getting involved with wall
street
and messing up these people's but i'm
feeling this so i need to talk about
what i'm feeling and that is very
selfish
you don't have to talk about what you're
feeling sometimes you want to not talk
about what you're feeling and talk about
other things that are more important
yeah if you're a representative you're
supposed to represent
other people not just yourself and talk
about yourself and be
self-censored and egotistical when
you're supposed to be talking about the
suffering of all the other people who
are
not doing good who are downtrodden who
are being screwed over time and time
again whose wages are going down
whose uh wealth is going down all
because of a broken system that you're
now literally taking selfies in front of
being like
well don't i look pretty aoc is little
trump yeah no
i should say for a long time the people
who follow her aren't cheering on her
policies because what are her policies
green new deal explain to me what the
green new deal is it's sort of i mean
literally
because i'm in favor of a green new deal
no joke i did a whole video on
on it two years ago when aoc was talking
about green new deal i was like this is
actually really cool
and i pulled up a poll that said 85
percent of people support the idea of
green new deal
you know why the simple way of
describing a green new deal
should the government allocate more
resources into
investing in developing and expanding
renewable energies
yeah what do you what do you think jack
yes i agree i agree with that do you
think so luke
you're against texas i i don't like any
government doing anything so
85 of people are like absolutely look
understanding and existing in this con
the confines of the existing
existing taxation system the us
government has tons of our money
and we think they should allocate more
towards green energy renewal projects
and things like that expanding
technology investing
so linger was a disaster but people are
still like hey mit look man we're trying
to do something cool and good and new
instead we get four and eight packages
in the billions of dollars trillions of
dollars
and aoc's green new deal what is it well
according to sciket chakrabarty her
former chief of staff it has nothing to
do with the environment it's all about
re reshaping the u.s economy it was
about creating
uh gender studies programs it was about
getting guaranteed college for people of
color
had nothing to do with the new deal with
renewing look we got crumbling bridges
and crumbling roads
crumbling infrastructure and we want to
help push america towards
more energy independence and what i
should say is more advanced energy
independence to secure our position as
an energy independent nation
yeah i like the idea of the investment
what aoc proposes isn't that
so i look at what people are talking
about with aoc and they can't
what are they really supporting did she
did she force nancy pelosi to
to put a floor vote on medicare for all
no she just blindly voted for her
she's not doing anything to actually
help progressives other than be a tribal
avatar for the
for for the tribe and what is she
calling for she's calling for big tech
censorship she's calling for the eroding
of civil liberties she's calling for a
bigger police states that of course will
of course
reign in on supposed domestic terrorism
threats she's talking about a new
patriot act
2.0 i mean these are policies that of
course go completely
against helping individuals what
actually does help people
well it's none of the policies that of
course aoc is pushing right now in my
opinion
i think it seems to me it seems to me
that there's an algorithm we're not
talking about right now and it's the one
that's in our head
we have an algorithm we are pre
determined to react to certain things
she is hacking our human algorithms much
like trump did much like trump
much like anybody who's successful
social media in a competition for
attention
it's the attention economy you got to
get attention how do you get attention
you appeal to people's emotions
you put the out there you trigger those
empathetic reactions and the byproduct
of getting attention in a positive way
because there is positive ways of doing
it but the byproduct of doing this is
we're just
splitting into these empathetic tribes
you can watch the same thing with two
different people
you take away two different outcomes two
different perspectives
and you can't understand at all what the
other person is saying
i read i tweeted something about this
today jacksobic retweeted me so i got
i got the jacksobic title wave of
comments and he has a lot of haters
bro and the people that were responding
and the hate the hate camp man they
can't see it and they think that we're
all just monsters and doubles and
terrible people because because we think
she's manipulating us
here's what i love so uh there's this
big battle going on between marjorie
taylor green
you know and and the democrats they want
her removed from her committees for
things she has said previously that
are fairly you know insane and bombastic
don't get me wrong
and uh it was reported that you know
kevin mccarthy
minor minority leader in the in the
house was negotiating with her to like
take her off one committee
i just responded with republicans are
such pathetic losers
now think about the context of that
kevin mccarthy democrats demand
margie taylor green be removed from all
committees but kevin mccarthy says only
one
and then i called republicans pathetic
losers
the immediate assumption from a bunch of
these leftists was why are you defending
marjorie taylor green
and i said what did i say in her defense
it's a it's a tribal assumption
what what if the what if my point was
that
instead of just booting her off for
committees the republicans were
only were refusing and and and cow
towing to cue anon
and that's why i was calling him
pathetic losers i just called them
losers
and immediately the tribal assumption
was i was in defense
of marjorie taylor green i don't mean
not i don't mean to call out your
methods but you
do tweet those vague mirrors or
projecting uh tweets all the time you
mean like
vague like as in it's like the magic
mirror it's like yes it's like whatever
people respond
reveals the way they interpreted it
literally why i didn't yeah yeah and
it's it's effective but the truth was i
don't care if the republicans kick
crawford committees or don't regardless
they are pathetic losers they're
republican politicians
so i was like i don't care indeed i i
figured it was something everybody would
agree
with right either you're a republican
who says why are they coming after
marjory taylor agreement and bowing down
to the democrats
or you're a democrat saying why won't
they remove this crazy woman either way
they're spineless pathetic losers who
can't just make a decision
they're like what do we do what if we
only hurt her a little what if only you
strip her
a little bit it's like pick one dude
either you're with the democrats and
you're saying she's bad or you stand
over people who just got elected to your
party
spineless i don't care if they keep her
under they don't keep her on i think she
said
crazy stuff and i understand people are
mad about it i think there's been
democrats who've said crazy stuff maybe
margie taylor green said some crazy or
crazier stuff online but regardless
pick one they can't even do that who
whose side are they on
you know the republicans just love to do
whatever they're told
in a very pathetic and weak way it's
it's it's it's
fairly sad but uh but no you bring up a
good point
i almost always make these magic mirror
tweets as you call them
the goal is whatever tribe someone's on
they see what they want to see and it's
hilarious to watch them react to it
i just i i you know i got to say i it's
michael malus man i learned from the
best
yeah i didn't come up with this stuff
it's hilarious to like kick over an ant
hill and watch the ants scramble
kind of like you must understand yeah
but he's not destroying anything no no
you're like finding joy in their in
their suffering and confusion who's
who's suffering these people that are
answering i genuinely think
i genuinely think that republicans are
pathetic spineless losers
and i kept it fairly vague so that it
wasn't
overtly descript towards a particular
individual like you also made a video
about it where you went deeper into it
i think about what uh you you led a
video i heard you lead a video earlier
today republicans are spineless losers
you actually called them losers in a
video
absolutely and that was a way for you to
explain it but in the tweet
it's it's on it's like a vague and
people are freaking out and so what
well it seems like you enjoy watching
people freak out i don't look at the
convention tweets
i don't go and check what people are
saying responsibilities you just say the
most part the people
you did talking about their response
yeah i was a guy who said who was
immediate response
to me after i tweeted it was like you
know
you are clearly supporting marjory
taylor so weird because i completely
stopped doing that
doing vague tweets i'm trying to be as
specific
in tweets as possible so that i don't
confuse people it's no no no it
you it's impossible it's literally
impossible people will just tweet nasty
things for no reason i mean look at seth
rogen
do you see the seth rogen jonathan k
interaction jonathan k
who uh he's cool at isn't he yeah
jonathan k
is uh i don't i'm not super familiar
with what his exact title would be but
he writes for quillette and he tweeted a
joke
about something do you remember what it
was jack i don't know it was shampoo
oh yes that's right he was using he was
like okay about it so he tweeted this
joke
it was a silly little joke where he was
like for the longest time i've been
using dog shampoo and didn't realize
until i went to the store
and tried to buy it and then notice in
big bold letters it says pet shampoo and
i should have realized
and seth rogen responded with like
you're stupid something like that
and he responded with like okay i'm is
making a silly joke as of
self-deprecating humor and seth rogen
was like so what i said you're stupid
that's that's that's the point of
twitter that's why you don't
use twitter legitimately no matter what
you say
you passively make a joke where you are
deriding yourself in silly humor
targeting no one and a a
multi-millionaire celebrity will
will insult you for no reason it's free
none whatsoever
so i don't give specific tweets i see
the republicans i see what they're doing
instead of me writing out 500 paragraphs
explaining everything wrong with
republicans i say these people are
spinal
spineless losers they won't stand up for
anything they don't defend anything
they just say well we'll do a little bit
of what you want democrats and then not
do anything not all of them right
99 yeah you got thomas master's cool
rand paul's cool
josh hawley's pretty cool uh uh ted cruz
is okay
you know that's pretty cool well i
disagree with dan crunch on a lot of
things but i think he's an alright guy i
just really disagree with him on a lot
of things
see i just post a bunch of memes and we
have to we have to remember social media
is not real
life but it's becoming real life and a
lot of the nastiness is incentivized
again
uh by the algorithm uh when you do have
that drama when you do have that thing
again we're talking about this again
from the very beginning it's all about
emotions if you're able to spark a
negative one
they've done psychological studies
showing that gets more of your attention
that that spurs the fight-or-flight
uh reflexes and uh here we are you know
dude we're talking about the same thing
there so i used to work for these
nonprofits this is uh now
almost 14 years ago i did fundraising
for nonprofits and it was street
canvassing
you guys know those people on the street
that are waving to you saying like you
have a minute to talk about the
environment or whatever that you don't
want to have eye contact with yes
yes because if you have eye candy they
got you yeah yeah but you know
i'll tell you guys a secret technique
you know the secret technique is i could
get
anybody in the world to stop for me
anyone in the world you want to know
what the trick is
break dancing nope trip them you don't
ask them anything you just hold out your
hand
you walk up to him stand in front of him
and you hold out your hand and shake it
and then once you're shaking your hand
you say i'm going to talk to you about
the environment
it's the same way if you meet a girl and
you want to get no no no no no you're
off with physical contact that's not it
it's that i'm physically holding them
and they can't leave and then you get
peppers
there too but i'm shaking their hand you
see it's a clever hi
sales tactic that came out a little
psycho when i said you grab their hand
and you shake it
and they can't walk away while you're
talking to them and then with your other
end you hand them your clipboard they
grab it
and then you let go and then you put
your hands you you you hold your hands
to your side
now they're physically holding your
property they'll try and hand it to you
but they can't they can't leave as long
as they're holding it anyway i digress
when i worked at these offices they
would have these ev these events where
they would mass purge the entire office
firing 40 to 50 people in a single day
because
demoralization is like a virus
so you have 40 or 50 people and you need
them doing sales
for a cause which means they have to be
passionate and positive
they go out in the street and they say
dude i need your help right now we gotta
save the world
man i believe in you do you believe in
me let's do this give me your credit
card now how much we're gonna tell
how much money i'm taking from you so
getting people to feel good was was
paramount
there's also also ways where you can
make people feel regret or or
loss and make them feel a sense of
urgency to get them to donate
but what happens when this when the when
the fundraiser the canvasser can't do it
they get frustrated they get really
close to that sign up that membership
and they fail
now they're getting frustrated and angry
they try again but that frustration
persists
now the people who are walking up to and
see this angry person with a furled brow
and they're like i don't want to talk to
you you're nasty and pissed off
that person comes back to the office
their friends say how was your day it
was awful dude people are such awful
people i hate this place
and then the other people feel that
negativity the negative negativity
started to spread like a virus
so all of these offices what they would
do is they would have no joke 40 to 50
people in the office
all training and they would do debriefs
at the end of every day when people come
back to the office and
then they would ask you how was your day
if too many people said negative things
they would immediately fire every single
person
to stop the spread of the negativity
virus you're making me think and then
re-hire an entirely new team in the next
week the negativity viruses in congress
oh absolutely but it's on social media
and it can't unless we get rid of all of
them it's going to persist no i'm not
talking about it
still have it i'm talking about twitter
new people go in like aoc
she got you have people who are overtly
negative being negative to other people
spreading around a negativity
demoralization
mind virus thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time